for a generic redox reaction where the
reactants turn into the products the
free energy is related to the potential
for the redox reaction
the equation that relates free energy
and potential
is given by delta g is equal to negative
nfe
delta g is the instantaneous difference
in free energy between the reactants and
the products n refers to the number of
electrons that are transferred in the
redox reaction
f is faraday's constant which tells us
the charge carried by one mole of
electrons
so one mole of electrons carries 96
485 coulombs
e refers to the potential of the redox
reaction you could also call this the
voltage of the redox reaction if the
reactants and products are both in their
standard states we can add the
superscript not to delta g and the
superscript naught to e
so we can use this equation to calculate
delta g naught from e naught or vice
versa we could calculate e naught from
delta g naught and remember that delta g
naught is connected to the equilibrium
constant k
by this equation delta g naught is equal
to negative rt natural log of k where r
is the ideal gas constant and t is the
temperature and because delta g naught
is a part of both of these two equations
these two equations connect the standard
potential e naught
to the standard change in free energy
delta g naught which is then connected
to the equilibrium constant k
so let's look at an example of a redox
reaction where we know the value for the
standard potential e naught and first
we're going to calculate delta g naught
and then from delta g naught we're going
to calculate the equilibrium constant k
so here's our redox reaction and we're
going to calculate delta g naught at 25
degrees celsius from e naught so for
this redox reaction e naught is equal to
positive 1.54 volts and our goal is to
calculate delta g naught at 25 degrees
celsius
in our redox reaction silver one plus is
being reduced to solid silver
and solid chromium is being oxidized to
chromium three plus
now that we've identified what's being
oxidized and what's being reduced
let's write the oxidation and reduction
half reactions
so for our reduction half reaction we
have silver one plus gaining an electron
to form solid silver and for the
oxidation half reaction solid chromium
is turning into chromium three plus and
losing three electrons
next we need to figure out how many
electrons are being transferred in our
redox reaction
in the reduction half reaction the
silver one plus cation is gaining an
electron but in the oxidation half
reaction solid chromium is losing three
electrons and we need to make the number
of electrons equal therefore we need to
multiply the first half reaction through
by a factor of three
so now when we add together our
reactants so all the reactants on one
side and all the products on the other
side the three electrons cancel out and
give us our overall redox reaction
because three electrons three moles of
electrons are being transferred in our
redox reaction
n is equal to three
and since we know that n is equal to
three and the standard potential is
equal to positive one point five four
volts we're ready to plug into our
equation to calculate delta g naught so
i went ahead and rewrote our redox
reaction and our goal is to calculate
delta g naught we already know what n is
we already know what e naught is and f
is faraday's constant here's our
equation with everything plugged in
n is equal to three there were three
moles of electrons transferred in our
redox reaction per mole of reaction
f is faraday's constant which is 96 485
coulombs per mole of electrons
and the standard voltage was equal to
1.54 volts one volt is equal to one
joule per coulomb so i went ahead and
changed the units from volts to joules
per coulomb
next we can cancel out some units so
moles of electrons will cancel out
and coulombs will cancel out and that
gives us joules per mole of reaction
and after we do the math we find that
delta g naught at 25 degrees celsius for
this redox reaction is equal to negative
4.46 times 10 to the fifth joules per
mole of reaction we could also write
this in terms of kilojoules per mole of
reaction so delta g naught is equal to
negative 446 kilojoules per mole of
reaction
notice that a positive voltage and the
negative in the equation means that we
get a negative sign in the final answer
and when delta g naught is negative the
reaction is thermodynamically favored
which means at 25 degrees celsius
silver cations will react with solid
chromium to form solid silver and
chromium three plus ions
and what this example shows us is
whenever the voltage is positive that
means a thermodynamically favored
reaction because delta g naught will be
negative
now that we've calculated delta g naught
for our reaction let's calculate the
equilibrium constant k at 25 degrees
celsius
so we need to plug in our value for
delta g naught the ideal gas constant
the temperature in kelvin and will solve
for the equilibrium constant
i've gone ahead and plugged everything
into our equation so here's the value
for delta g naught in joules per mole of
reaction the ideal gas constant is equal
to 8.314 joules per kelvin mole of
reaction and 25 degrees celsius if we
add 273 to that we get 298 kelvin
looking at the units kelvin cancels out
and so does joules per mole of reaction
and solving for k the equilibrium
constant is approximately equal to 10 to
the 78th power and since k is such an
extremely large number that tells us the
reaction essentially goes to completion
and all the reactants turn into products
so for a reaction like this it's not
necessary to have equilibrium arrows in
here we can just draw an arrow going to
the right
and remember we started with a positive
standard potential for this redox
reaction so to summarize what we've seen
with these calculations a positive value
for the standard potential leads to a
negative value for delta g naught so a
thermodynamically favored redox reaction
and a negative value for delta g naught
leads to an equilibrium constant k that
is greater than one
we've just seen what happens to delta g
naught and the equilibrium constant k
when the standard potential is positive
or greater than zero now let's think
about a generic redox reaction where the
standard potential is negative so e
naught is less than zero so let's think
about the sign for delta g naught if we
plug in a negative value for the
standard potential
so if we have a negative voltage the two
negative signs in the equation will give
us a positive value for delta g naught a
positive value for delta g naught means
that the forward reaction of reactants
turning into products is a
thermodynamically unfavorable reaction
and if we were to plug in a positive
value for delta g naught we would find
that the equilibrium constant k would be
less than one
and when k is less than one that tells
us whenever the reaction reaches
equilibrium there will be a lot more
reactants than products
let's look at a quick summary of what
we've learned from these examples the
standard potential e naught and the
standard change in free energy delta g
naught are related by the equation on
the left and delta g naught and the
equilibrium constant k are related by
the equation on the right when e naught
is greater than zero delta g naught is
less than zero and the reaction is
thermodynamically favored which means at
equilibrium there'll be more products
than reactants and the equilibrium
constant k will be greater than one
however when e naught is less than zero
delta g naught is greater than zero and
the reaction is thermodynamically
unfavored which means at equilibrium
there'll be more reactants than products
and the equilibrium constant k will be
less than one